foreign
hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear we're talking about another Jello
movie today I know how much you guys
enjoyed giallo July and I enjoyed uh
watching all the movies and making them
but as I said on there I probably I was
going to keep sprinkling giallo movies
throughout the other months too I
probably will do another whole like
jello month at some point in the future
as well but you know every now and then
I'm gonna be thrown in a Jello movie
because I like them and there's like a
lot that I haven't covered uh including
this one that we're talking about today
so Sergio Martino we've talked about him
before uh several times matter of fact
uh he's actually a name that anybody
with even like a passing familiarity uh
with yellow films should probably know
already now he made a bunch of different
movies in a bunch of different genres
but in the two years between 1971 and
1973 he actually directed five really
really iconic examples of uh the genre
all all of which are fantastic and I
think if if I'm not if I'm remembering
correctly uh four of them that I've
already covered on here they were the
strange Vice of Mrs Ward uh your Vice is
a locked room and only I have the key
all the colors of the dark torso and the
one that we're going to be talking about
today so if I have covered those other
four then this will make like his big
five you know what I mean like I said he
did do some other movies like later on
but these are kind of the ones that he's
best known for so this movie is called
The Case of the Scorpion's tail and it
came out in 1971 and this was actually
the second movie that he directed in
this you know uh incredible run of five
that he had and it's a very
um I had actually seen it before and
then I watched it again like for this
video and I actually really liked it
much better the second time it's very
um I I really admired like the script a
lot more it's very tightly plotted it's
very entertaining and it has like some
really cool like Cinema photography like
some really nice shots has a really good
script with like a lot of really
surprising twists and turns and has some
really really satisfyingly grisly kills
which I kind of feel like his other ones
I mean I guess his other ones were kind
of gory too but I mean this one has like
some really some ones where I was like
watching it I was like holy [ __ ] like I
forgot yeah so this one has like some
pretty [ __ ] up uh murders in it too so
at the beginning of the movie We're
introduced to this beautiful icy blonde
woman named Lisa Baumer now she's played
by Evelyn Stewart which I believe is the
pseudonym of the actress uh Ida Galley
who I think is Italian now this woman is
like the two-timing wife of this jet
setting Rich dude named Kurt Baumer
now as I said at the beginning of the
movie uh Lisa is busily banging her
little scruffy side piece that she has
going on there
and she gets a phone call I mean
basically she's like on the phone being
like yeah he's leaving on the flight
today yeah come on over like it's that
kind of thing
so uh so while they're in bed like the
phone wakes them up in the middle of the
night but this phone call that she gets
actually informs her that her presumably
Lego size husband has been killed in a
plane crash if you've seen the movie and
you've seen the effect of like the plane
you'll probably know what I'm talking
about like why I make that joke because
the plane is just kind of like they show
it like they intercut like her on the
phone well actually they intercut her
like having sex with her boyfriend and
they then they intercut like her talking
on the phone with this pretty clearly
like toy plane that's like against this
black backdrop with like a real moon in
the back it's like kind of like a
composite shot and it's like it really
made me laugh like the first time I saw
it because
I was just kind of like how did he fit
in that little bitty model plane and
then yeah so then like it blows up so uh
so yeah so he's presumably been killed
uh in this tiny uh toy plane explosion
now uh she gets this news and she's
basically like oh yeah um I know all
about that place oh I mean uh oh man
what a shame that is uh I loved that guy
more than life itself yes indeedy yes I
did now uh so after this whole situation
helping her through her terrible grief
at the loss of her husband loss of her
husband is the fact that uh poor old
exploded Kurt had an insurance policy
that will make Lisa a million dollars
richer all she has to do is fly to
Athens Greece to pick up the check in
person and cha-ching like now she's a
rich lady now she tells the head of the
insurance firm that held the policy that
her and Kurt were pretty much like all
but separated like they lived kind of
separate lives and that she legit for
real had no idea that she was the
beneficiary of such large s she tries to
say but Mr insurance man is not buying
it now since the company suspects that
maybe Lisa had something to do with the
little model plane explosion that
shuffled off Kurt's mortal coil they
decide they're gonna hire crack
Insurance Investigator and rakishly
Suave [ __ ] Peter Lynch who's
played by George Hilton who's in a [ __ ]
ton of yellow movies and in a [ __ ] out
of Sergio Martino movies as well so they
hire him to follow Lisa's little tight
ass around and see what dubious [ __ ] uh
she might be up to now because he's not
being real subtle about the whole
following thing I mean basically she
goes to check into the hotel and he's
standing right there like staring at her
like really creepily and then follows
her to the elevator it's just it's a
whole thing and I'm just kind of like
I'm like can't you like tone it down a
little bit it's like she's gonna know
that you're following her bro so uh
presumably yeah it's like so he
approaches her at dinner hey can I set
it you sit with you or whatever and
she's like might as well you've been
crawling up my [ __ ] Grill all day
long and uh yeah so she even knows like
who he is like she knows his name she
knows like he's from the insurance
company she's like yeah you guys think I
had something to do with my husband
dying and you're following me around I
get it you know there's that uh so she's
got that going on but uh as it turns out
she's not really all that worried about
Peter Lynch following her around because
she's got bigger problems to deal with
another thing that's going on is that
Kurt her presumably exploded husband uh
had this very severe looking mistress
named Lara and Lara and has this like
lawyer she calls him the lawyer but he
also looks like the muscle you know what
I mean so he's like lawyer slash one man
brute Squad and his name is Sharif and
the two of them
want to get their hands on some of
Kurt's Sweet Death cash as well because
Lara is just kind of like hey I'm the
mistress and I deserve half of that [ __ ]
like he was gonna change the will anyway
that's why you killed him blah blah now
it turns out that they've already
murdered Lisa's former boyfriend back in
London who was like a heroin addict and
he was actually trying to blackmail her
with a letter in which he like she
didn't say hey I'm gonna kill my husband
or anything like that but she did say
something about like getting rid of him
or something that sounded like a little
bit suspicious and so they were like um
yeah so they went to his apartment and
killed him and then uh then they got
hold of the letter and now they're kind
of like admittedly their whole like
scheme they're trying to blackmail her
too they're basically like hey we want
half the money
um and she's like yeah no um because you
know what I mean it's a million dollars
and uh so she doesn't really uh Buckle
under their little threats or whatever
and so they proceed to try to kill her
like she just like takes off and they're
just like oh [ __ ] we didn't think she
would actually like you know run away so
they had like chase after her and they
try to stab her and [ __ ] like that now
Peter Lynch the insurance investigator
who's been following around because he
was following her around
um he saw this whole the shenanigans
take place so he actually manages to
save her from getting stabbed by them
but as it turns out her troubles are
just beginning now because she plans on
getting this million dollars as quickly
as possible and getting the [ __ ] out of
Dodge probably a good idea uh in this
situation Lisa cashes her million dollar
check and makes arrangements to fly to
Tokyo that night like to meet up with
her lover so she calls for a cab she's
gonna take a flight out at 9pm or
whatever unfortunately though for her uh
the security at the hotel she's staying
at doesn't really seem all that up to
Snuff because somebody breaks into her
room and uh basically slices her to
Ribbons this is another example of this
was the kind of the first Plot show us
the twist that surprises me because you
think you're going to be following Lisa
the whole time because she's like the
main character but literally I think
it's like 25 minutes in like maybe uh
she gets [ __ ] murdered so you're just
kind of like oh okay we're doing this
we're doing a psycho type of situation I
see what you're doing I see what you're
doing but yeah so she gets killed like
pretty much right away and somebody
steals the little uh the little suitcase
that she had all of the money bundles in
now as I said since Peter has been
following Lisa around uh the cops
suspect that he either killed her or he
knows more about her murder than he's
letting on now he says look Rose I was
just following her for work like they
thought that maybe she had something to
do with the death of her husband and
like the insurance company and they call
the insurance company and it all checks
out they're like oh yeah you are here on
a job but they still kind of think he's
suspicious anyway so you know they kind
of like are crawling up his ass like the
whole [ __ ] movie now he does actually
tell them about Lara and Sharif and so
they're like okay well they find out
about that too at kind of at the same
time and they go to Laura's apartment to
interview her about hey did you kill
Lisa and while literally while the cop
is in there and I think it's like the
middle of the day too I'm not really
sure because it's inside but the cop is
like inside interviewing Laura and Peter
is like hanging out out in the hallway
and somebody like legit tries to kill
him like with a hatchet right in the
[ __ ] house like right in front of her
apartment like while the cop is like
right inside I was like wow that's a
bold move to say the least just right
out there in the hallway you find out
why later on but yeah so then after that
you kind of have your standard giallo
murder mystery happening you got your
kind of world weary [ __ ] talking
investigators you got a little bit of a
budding Love Story between Peter and
this other woman named Cleo who's played
by Anita strinberg uh she's actually
like a journalist that's been a assigned
to the case she's a journalist or a
photographer I can't remember and uh so
she kind of so they kind of like become
entangled and that's a whole thing and
there's just like a whole Fisherman's
Platter of red herrings as there usually
are in this one uh you know people who
are at first suspected of the murders
like for example Lara and Sharif they
turn up dead themselves so you're like
who could it be now uh and it becomes
clear like as it goes on that whatever
it is that's happening like this plot
that's unfolding is way more complicated
than it seemed at first blush and matter
of fact I'm like glad that I watched it
the second time because I think the
first time I was just kind of like wait
what like you know what I mean because
the plot's like a little bit it's a
little bit convoluted but if you pay
attention like it actually absolutely
does make sense so what I mean what
you're trying to find out is who is
bumping off all of these seemingly
unrelated people like some of the people
at first that get killed everybody's
like oh it has to do with Kurt Baumer
and they exploded plane and like the
wife trying to get the insurance payout
but then like other people start getting
killed too and they're like what the
[ __ ] that person didn't seem to have
anything to do with that whole situation
so they don't really know like what
connects them all and there's also like
like I said there's some other red
herrings there's like this real sketchy
like Interpol uh officer supposedly that
comes there to work on the investigation
and uh you know he has like an injured
hand at some point when you know there
was a woman that like bit the hand of
the killer there's all this other kind
of stuff then for a while they're
thinking well maybe Kurt Baumer like
isn't really dead like maybe he faked
his death like to collect on his own
insurance policy was him and his wife in
on it and then he decided to bump her
off and keep all the money for himself
so it's like there's all these different
like possibilities that are kind of like
floating around and you're not really
sure like which way it's gonna go you
know and or it could be something
totally different like it could be just
something way more Sinister way more
convoluted like I said this is pretty
convoluted and you really actually do
have to pay attention to the end where
everything's kind of explained because I
think I missed like some of the details
like on the last on the first watch but
on the second one I was kind of like oh
okay I got you it absolutely does make
sense so don't worry about that I have
to say too like apropos nothing
there's a scene in this one and it kind
of highlighted something that happens a
lot in geology movies and I don't know
if I've mentioned this before I probably
have but why on Earth do female
characters in geolo movies not every
single one but I've seen it enough times
for me to like remember it and like
remark upon it every single female
character that she just kind of like
stands there helplessly
and stares at the door while the
murderer is busting it down it's like
you know ladies you can run away perhaps
or you can like find a weapon and fight
back perhaps that's another option that
you have available to you I don't really
know like it's really weird it almost
kind of seems like
you know just because a dude goes to the
trouble of breaking into your house that
doesn't really mean that you have some
kind of obligation to him to like allow
him to kill you you can like fight back
or like climb out the window or some
[ __ ] they never do that they just kind
of like stand there get somebody like oh
[ __ ] and I'm like dude there's a window
right there or it's like you know
there's a whole kitchen full of knives
like please you had time like you had
time to like formulate a plan please
like me but yeah it happens in this one
and it just kind of like made me laugh
so it's just kind of like stood out
because I've seen it in other films as
well and it's not I mean to be fair it's
not just yellow movies I've seen it in
other older horror movies just in
general where women would just kind of
like here comes the Killer and they're
like oh no when they could just like run
to the side or something like that
they're just like well I guess I just
have to stay here and get killed that's
just how it goes because I'm a lady in a
horror movie I don't know how to run
away or like fight back or anything like
that but I don't know I just thought
that was funny because there was a scene
like that in this one and it just kind
of like reminded me the whole thing so
uh so yeah so the mystery like I said
that is very very complicated well I
don't know if it's that complicated but
it's it's fairly complicated you know
what I mean but uh the key to the whole
uh cannoli as it were uh turns out to be
this uh filigreed like gold cufflink
which is in the shape of a scorpion
which gets found in Cleo's apartment
after a dude breaks in and tries like
unsuccessfully to kill her so hence the
name of the movie being the case of the
Scorpion's tale there is actually
something having to do with the Scorpion
it's a cuff length that looks like a
scorpion oh and I should say too that
Sergio Martino also did another gello
movie that was called the Scorpion with
two tails that came out in 1982 but I'm
pretty sure I've seen it but it was a
long time ago and I don't think it has
anything to do with this one like it's
not a sequel or anything like that so
I'd say this one there's actually like
some really good misdirection uh as to
who the actual killer is and I'm not
gonna spoil the ending but I will say
that this movie kind of has a real
enjoyable subversion in of some of the
more common tropes of the genre which I
uh quite uh which I quite liked there's
also as I mentioned some added Spice in
there with so like there's some really
really graphic kills particularly one
guy that gets killed uh by having his
eye gouged out by a like a piece of a
broken bottle it's pretty nasty like I'm
sitting there going holy crap like Lucia
full cheat to the white courtesy phone
you know it was that kind of thing I had
forgotten that that [ __ ] scene was in
there I was like God damn I was like
that was [ __ ] up you know I mean
yellow movies in general they do usually
like have pretty bloody kills but this
one had like some pretty bloody kills
even because I've seen some giala movies
that were just kind of like oh stab and
that's it but that eye gouging was uh
something else yeah I had forgotten all
about that and uh you know there's your
standard kind of jail movie nudity you
got some hotties in there and they have
like some cool outfits and there's some
cool interiors and [ __ ] like that uh but
yeah this is a pretty great
entertaining giallo movie with uh you
know enough plot curveballs to kind of
keep you guessing and it's definitely
like a stellar example of the form and
it's like amazing that these five movies
came out within you know two years and
you know they're still remember to this
day as being like really good examples
of it and Sergio Martino like did all of
them in that in that short of a time
span so that's pretty awesome so if
you've seen the case of the Scorpion's
tale what did you think about it um or
does it sound like interesting enough
for you to want to see it's actually on
2B for free at the moment uh as at least
as of this recording if you'd like to
watch it so tell me your thoughts about
it in the comments and I will see you
guys again on the next one bye